Wally Szczerbiak CBS Turner Sports
college basketball analyst and hey Wally
do you remember who you were compared to
when you were coming out of college
Larry Bird you know that was kind of the
comparison back when I was the sixth
pick in the draft oh wow yeah that's
pretty good but hard hard to live up to
I know didn't quite meet up to those a
pretty good career you know made an
all-star team bunch of playoff runs but
um you know he was obviously tremendous
so but that was pretty pretty flattering
and complimentary to to be compared and
in that light but you played against him
VIN you I didn't I just missed him I
actually my first season was the first
season that the Boston Garden wasn't in
existence so I unfortunately missed
playing at the old garden would have
loved to have played there it was it was
the fleet center my uh my um rookie here
so I just miss playing against Larry and
then doug mcdermott now you got players
being compared to you I know and you
know Doug McDermott was with the Knicks
and I thought he would definitely you
know grow into a player like I did you
know and do what I did in the pros you
know so far he's been on four teams and
he's been traded around he hasn't really
been able to expand his game he's a
great shooter it's 40% three-point
shooter but I thought he would ever be
able to do more inside the arc a little
bit of posting up you know get to the
free-throw line here and there it just
goes to show you I thought he was you
know incredible in college National
Player of the Year I was 25 points a
game and a tough Big East and dominated
that league but you never know how guys
going to translate to the NBA he's going
to be solid he's going to have a good
career but I was expecting him to you
know do a little bit more how did life
change for you when Miami of Ohio got on
the map during the n-c-double-a
tournament well you know I'm a pretty
humble guy so I tried to stay as
grounded as possible but it was really
like a coming-of-age as far as you know
hitting the national scene I'd played on
the Goodwill Games team that summer with
Elton Brand Andre Miller and we won the
gold medal at the Garden against a lot
of international teams so that's when
the NBA scouts started to have me
but I projected as a lottery pick but
when you're playing at Miami of Ohio and
back in 99 the games weren't televised
my parents had to watch the scores on
the ticker on the bottom of the TV so
not too many people knew about me so to
have that run in the NCAA tournament
that's really where you know you make
your name on the national scene and it
was great to you know play good
basketball in the tournament he's one
loser being former NBA player working
for CBS Sports brought to you by the
2018 Mercedes AMG e-class a suite of
innovative technologies one of the most
intelligent cars on the road go to MBUSA
dot-com or visit your local dealership
to schedule your test drive today all
right handicap these games coming up how
does this all play out well Kentucky we
thought had the toughest roads of the
Final Four now you know they have to go
through nine seed in k-state without
maybe their best player and Dean wait to
get to the Elite Eight and then they're
looking at oil with Chicago and Nevada
an 11 seed in a seven seed so you never
know what's gonna happen in this
tournament the fact the top four seeds
lost in the South Region is just
incredible to me and it's why my bracket
is completely blown up so they have a
pretty nice road to the Final Four they
would be the favorites in the south then
in the West
I really thought UNC was going to be
able to handle business down there but
Texas A&M just wiped the floor with them
boy today break it bring it big time and
they got some really solid big men
inside and then Xavier goes down the
number one seed
so zags are looking pretty good but
don't sleep on Florida State that team
has a ton of talent and you know
Michigan well put it what a game they
had you know what that buzzer beater
getting by there so I think I think you
know Michigan's probably the favorite
with the way they can play defense I
don't think they've hit their max
offensively in the tournament they've
been struggling a little bit shooting
the ball but their defense has gotten
them into the sweet 16 so if they can
get both ends of the floor clicking I
think they're going to be good on that
end and then it's Duke and Nova on the
other side I mean Villanova is looking
as good as any team in the tournament
and so is Duke so I think those two
teams are going to end up in the in the
final four out of the east and out of
the Midwest so I give you the first pick
in the NBA Draft
you've taken Bagley
deandre Aiden I'm taking Aiden I just
think his strength
you know he's seven foot two and he
moves so fluidly he's going to continue
to expand his jump shot out on the
perimeter you know he and defensively he
moves his feet fairly well so he can
guard pick-and-rolls Bagley's a special
talent and it's totally a toss-up it
really is and the only thing I would be
concerned with is when Durant went to
and you know you look at what happened
out of that raft and Bagley could have a
Durant type career I think he's just so
gifted offensively and the game comes so
easy to him offensively and he'll
continue to get better defensively that
um that would be my only fear and worry
so maybe Bagley's kind of a safer choice
but DeAndre Eaton boy and if he stays
healthy and continues to progress that
guy's a man-child at a young age I don't
know if you saw the news you would be
surprised by the news betray young
announced that he was going pro concerns
yeah I do listen the guy is a gift to
the way he sees the floor the way he
passes the way he can get by his
defender and the way he can shoot but he
is small and he is a little slight and
frail and going up against big bodies in
the NBA I don't know how his body's
gonna fill out and mature he is an
absolute sieve on the defensive end of
the floor he does not even try even and
that's gonna have to change when you get
to the NBA because as you know you're
going up against some good point guards
on a nightly basis if you want to be a
starter in the NBA so he's got a lot of
work to do on that end his teammates
really you know they didn't step up for
him I mean he got those guys a lot of
open shots a lot of open looks he made
incredible passes and there are times
his teammates didn't finish so when he
gets to the NBA he's going to be playing
with stars all around him which are
going to make him better and he's going
to make everyone else better because the
gift that he has as a point guard the
way he sees the floor and averaging you
know leading leading the country and
points and assists he can't shy away
from that but I just think there are
some physical questions that as long as
he answers those I think it's gonna be a
really good NBA player but Steve Nash
didn't play defense yeah but Steve Nash
was six
and you know Trey young is about six
feet six one you know he's got skinny
shoulders you know he gets pinballed
around a little bit but I agree he's
like a Steve Nash with the way he can
shoot the ball with his vision he's got
to get in the right system if he gets to
go in a Golden State system like Steph
Curry you know the sky's the limit for
him but if he goes to a different
coaching system where you know they slow
the game down a little bit and they
don't give him complete autonomy and
freedom to take some of those shots and
make some of this mistakes that he makes
because you know he's had ten turnover
games because he just has total freedom
then I think he might struggle but if he
goes to the right system and the way the
NBA is playing with the up-tempo it
should fit his style and his skill set
perfectly did you ever wonder how Nash
was so successful because if we had a
pickup game and you didn't know who he
was he might be the last guy picked
you're right but he played in perfect
system with Mike D'Antoni so that
maximized his talents he was also very
good with Dallas with Dirk Nowitzki and
Michael Finley but when he went and
played with D'Antoni every offensive
player me included dreams of playing in
his system it's just the best system in
basketball to play you know you push the
ball at the floor you're able to get
into rhythm if you missed one shot
you're not worried about when you're
going to get the next shot cuz you're
gonna get another shot very quickly
because he really encourages you to be
aggressive to play with confidence to
shoot the three-ball and you know he's
great for shooters and Steve Nash is one
of the best percentage shooters of all
time 50% 40% 90% I mean I was incredible
the way he could do that you know year
after year and hence he got those two
MVPs so he was a good player all around
and then that system Mike D'Antoni
system which I think every offensive
minded player in basketball who watches
it or plays it would love to play and
maximize his talents Mike D'Antoni's
underrated with with totally being an
offensive genius and and I know we love
to throw that around you know Paul
Westhead when what he did at Loyola
Marymount I thought was genius too but I
think what D'Antoni is doing now in real
time in the NBA and a very high level
and what he did at Phoenix you know it
didn't work out with the Knicks but I
mean
he's it's incredible to watch this and
it's not just James Harden he's making
other players look a lot better than
they probably are yeah and he's got the
whole league copy in his system and it's
a lot more fun for fans to watch the
game of basketball now as opposed to in
the 90s when Pat Riley was beating
people up and the scores were in the 80s
and the games were that was so bad and
fratello Mike fratello with Cleveland
did the same thing it was so bad that
basketball back then yeah and you know
the way Houston plays the way they push
the ball up the floor Golden State they
move it they pass it everyone is a part
of the game it's it's just a lot of fun
to watch and now that Mike D'Antoni has
gotten a defensive coordinator on his
staff to also scooch up the defensive
end of the floor that's why the Rockets
are just dominating the regular season
right now
Wally good stuff as always we appreciate
your time thanks for joining us
anytime Dan great to talk walleser back
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]